the david pakman show at david
pakman.com there's a dynamic that's
taking place within the world of space
exploration we are seeing nasa playing
sort of a smaller and smaller role in
the possible big advancements in space
technology and exploration and private
companies playing more and more of a
role now part of this has to do just
with the wider availability of
technology to private companies there
was a time where the technology that
NASA was working with was just not
really available to private companies to
build on and that has significantly
changed now we have companies like
SpaceX and Mars one and Boeing is
getting involved in space technology
research etc but it's also partially
because of what we're seeing under the
sort of paradigm of American government
budget priorities and there are people
many people in the United States who
really questioned the value of properly
funding NASA we saw a pretty big
controversy with NASA towards the
beginning of Donald Trump's
administration where NASA which in
addition to doing space stuff works on
climate research and NASA was directed
by the Trump administration to stop
doing all climate related stuff and Bill
Nye is someone who has spoken a lot
about NASA talking about how NASA has a
very recognizable brand but that now
between Boeing and Airbus and Lockheed
Martin and the space faring agencies of
France Germany Korea the United Arab
Emirates that NASA is actually sort of a
smaller and smaller piece of space
exploration Trump proposing a slight
budget cut for NASA so I have mixed
feelings about this I mean on the one
hand I am NOT one of these people who
says this has to be done by private
industry there are people who believe
that but I'm also not one of these
people who says the government needs to
lead the way I think one of the best
possible sort of scenarios is you have
private companies working in concert
with an organization
NASA as well as government contracts to
these companies which is what we're
seeing and I think that that's kind of a
great path forward I don't see this as a
one or the other type of thing there's a
lot of people who hear about this and
they say it's it's gotta be NASA or
nothing because the private industries
are a disaster or whatever that doesn't
make sense but the opposite also isn't
something I buy into yeah and I'm not
one of those people who think that it
has to be the United States that leads
the way on oh sure
I mean it could be China it could be
Russia I think it would be an
accomplishment for mankind as a whole
doesn't really matter which country gets
to Mars first for example sure but
certainly NASA seems to have the
infrastructure and the background to be
able to do it for SpaceX or any of these
other companies maybe at one point
they'll surpass NASA but I don't see
that happening in the near future
well who's who is the plan to go to Mars
soon you have not NASA actually be
accomplished I don't know yeah I don't
know yeah I mean it might not happen but
there's every in deep there's every
indication that it's not going to be
NASA that goes to Mars first now do you
do you really believe that when you say
you don't care if it's China or the US
that makes it to Mars first or are you
just saying that because you feel like
it's the right thing to say as a
progressive no no I mean I would note
here in the sense that I'd rather it be
the United States uh-huh but if Russia
or China was to get there and obviously
it would be you know years in the making
there would be so much planning behind
it by the time we actually got to a
point where they were going up there
yeah I wouldn't be upset that they beat
us to it you know I would just be proud
as a human being but we got off of the
planet so you started with you don't
care which country gets there first but
I guess what you really mean is you
wouldn't try to sabotage another country
getting there first I mean I wouldn't be
incredibly upset over it which is a
slightly different standard I tend to
agree with you I mean I don't I don't
have this idea that the US has to be
first or best or biggest at any
particular thing if you were to tell me
that it's a non friendly foreign
adversary who was going to be first
my concern wouldn't be in the actual
Mars thing it would be that we know that
there are so many ways in which
spacefaring technology can be used on
earth by militaries in ways that aren't
so good so that I think is what would be
my concern if it was like a non friendly
or so-called belligerent country
although two one
belligerent country is another person's
patriotic country I don't know I forgive
it was Russia or China may raise some
eyebrows the truth North Korea then we'd
be a lot more concern different
situation somehow I don't think that
North Korea is going to be the first
country to get to Mars
why why why don't I think that that's
going to go on state-run television they
may claim that they did oh yeah they'll
be the first North Korea will be the
first country to announce that they've
sent people to Mars but I don't think it
will actually be the first country maybe
a Shem people shortly after they win the
2018 and 2022 World Cups of course it
right after that they're gonna go to
Mars let's talk about drones there are
now some new papers from researchers at
William Carey University in Mississippi
which are studying the possibility of
using disaster drones to carry medical
kits and supplies to victims in a mass
casualty event even more quickly than an
ambulance could arrive and if you had
bystanders there could be something
equivalent to sort of like being a
trained first responder or trained in
first aid where bystanders who know how
to use these kits could use them to help
victims and they could also be there
waiting for first responders I think
that this is very interesting and
there's a lot of fear-mongering around
drones drones are going to be used for
this terrible thing or that terrible
thing and it's going to be absolute in
total chaos I think it's very
interesting to be thinking about ways in
which drones can be used for good
because I think there are many ways and
it's not just Amazon delivering stuff to
you within 20 minutes with a drone I
think that there is something very very
interesting here and in fact you could
even take this a step further there are
situations where helicopters are called
in to evacuate people for medical
purposes right medevacs as they're
referred to but helicopters can't land
just anywhere it's certainly reasonable
to think that within the next I don't
know six eight or ten years you could
have very small remotely powered drone
sort of compartments that could arrive
much more quickly than a helicopter and
transport someone to a hospital does
that person maybe maybe to I don't know
so I think that this is good I'm very
proud
I have a drone and I think that it's all
fantastic and wonderful assuming of
course that people are responsible not
everybody is I've seen videos of people
flying their drone right next to an
airport so that they could film
airplanes coming in for landing from the
sky which is completely illegal and we
need to make sure that that is going to
be enforced we probably need to have
drones hard-coded so that they will not
fly in these no-fly zones near airports
or something but I'm pretty Pro drone I
would say it's very interesting
apparently they tested it quite a few
times and they didn't experience any
mechanical failures and they also say
that the drones reduce response time by
16 minutes on average which is pretty
remarkable to me because I always think
of paramedic showing up much faster than
16 minutes well I guess it depends where
you are in the country it's an average
right so you're probably averaging in
the places where it takes the ambulance
five minutes to show up with places
where the closest ambulance is an hour
away so maybe on average it could you
know maybe the average time across the
entire country is like 22 minutes earth
I don't know right it also depends how
crowded the area is so I mean yeah you
know our minds are still in Las Vegas if
you have a crowd of people and the drone
ask to get specifically to the middle of
that crowd yeah be a lot easier for the
aircraft to do then for an ambulance to
get off of the road and navigate even
between difficulty into where it has to
be until you also get the first
responders right there weaving through
the crowd or whatever the case might be
yeah very very interesting I I'm I don't
know I I know that there are people who
write in and they're very negative about
both autonomous cars and about drones
but I feel like the engineering the sort
of logistical questions and dangers I
feel like they're gonna be sorted out I
don't know do you share that optimism
with me I think that I will figure it
out
well it couldn't hurt I mean I think one
of the most important things when it
comes to this exactly is getting the
qualified people to be able to apply the
first-aid yeah we have the the medical
equipment there but it's no it's no good
unless people know how to apply it
adequately yeah so I think that's more
important one idea I just thought of if
this were to be thought of at the sort
of government level would be people have
to in order to be able to use these
drone delivered supplies they need to be
certified
right once you get the certification you
get a code that you can use to open the
drone so the drone will only open or
maybe it's not even a code maybe it's a
retina scan
so the drone will only open itself up
and allow the supplies to be taken out
if it's someone who has passed the
certification who is there and has their
iris scanned or fingerprint or whatever
right I mean a lot would have to go
right in that scenario and also I mean
you know these minutes are precious they
matter and some of these life you know
risking situations sure so is it better
to just have anyone use this equipment
then no one at all I would say no okay I
would say they could do worse I would
say people could do more damage if
they're not trained properly but we're
getting into the minutiae the fact that
we're talking about the minutiae means
that there's something to the general
idea okay bad news from the traffic
fatality world sadly more Americans died
on American roadways last year than in
2015 and the numbers hit a nine-year
high according to the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration 37,000 461
people died in car accidents in 2016 up
more than five percent from the previous
year the agency pointed to the usual
reasons for the fatalities speeding and
failing to wear seatbelts the NHTSA also
tagged the increase to a 5.1 percent
jump in motorcycle deaths this is the
second year in a row that deaths have
increased prior to that you had six out
of seven years where motor motor vehicle
deaths decreased I think that this is
just absolutely horrible
I really think that this is one of the
areas and I know people always like to
say hey more people died because of cars
than guns so why don't we ban cars or
something like that and of course I find
that argument to be totally specious the
main point of cars is transportation not
to kill other people or oneself where is
the point of guns is to fire them in
self-defense or in aggression so I'm not
even buying into that but I think that
we are going to at some point need to
have a significant paradigm shift when
it comes to vehicle safety and it might
be autonomous cars I know people say oh
no the autonomous cars are going to be
terrible because the car will
to decide do I runs over someone on the
sidewalk to avoid running over two
people in the crosswalk and I won't be
able to stop or whatever that's gonna be
figured out the technology will be
figured out I think that autonomous
vehicles represent one of the biggest
possibilities for a significant increase
in automobile safety what else is going
to do it well and then you also lower
the risk of distracted driving I mean I
understand - in the transition process
at least you're going to have to be
focused on the road and being able to
take over the control if you ever have
to sure because sometimes these things
will malfunction at least from the onset
but then you eliminate you know not
eliminate that you reduce the chances of
someone getting into a fatal accident
because they were texting and driving
absolutely or they were just looking off
on the side of the road or whatever
because something else is going on
speaking to their friends I mean that
that's gonna be an improvement and again
the biggest causes of these vehicle
deaths are speeding and not wearing
seatbelts
just put the seat belt on yeah right
just just put the seat belt on and
you're already going to reduce these
numbers is it really that uncomfortable
to wear a seat belt even when I was the
teenager and so reckless and rebellious
absolutely I would still put on the seat
belt always that was something that my
mom told me to do when I was going to
disobey so many other things but that
was not gonna be the one thing growing
up it was always wear your seat belt I
never didn't put my seat belt on and
speeding I mean I really I really don't
speed I am acutely aware of the fact
that just even going 15% faster
increases your risk of an accident
injury or death significantly and on the
highway I you know yes
Massachusetts Turnpike will very often
move between 75 and 80 miles per hour
and I will go at that speed which which
I guess is speeding but what I mean is I
am always maintaining a safe following
distance and I am never going faster
than traffic is going I'm never that one
person who's passing everybody on the
left if traffic is moving at 75 to 80
I will go 75 to 80 yes but beyond that
I'm not speeding on surface roads I'm
not trying to aggressively pass people
because I know that that behavior
significantly puts me at additional risk
I'm always yelled at for driving like a
grandpa is that true yes by who uh
anyone else in the car oh really yeah
it's bad
also is it
actually safer to drive the speed of
traffic be at 75 80 miles an hour over
the speed limit versus just driving the
speed limit at all causing the slow lane
at all I don't know the answer to that I
don't know I genuinely don't know the
edge of that center lane is safest
center lane yeah because you avoid
merging traffic I guess I don't know
yeah highways or uh highways are a
complicated thing some of the math
around highways is fascinating like I've
seen analyses of how traffic jams start
because you know how sometimes there'll
be a traffic jam yeah and you get to
something and it doesn't really seem
like there's no accident there's no
merge traffic light but then the traffic
jam ends on the highway for example yeah
you never understand why it's there it's
very interesting why it develops the
traffic's thing right a truck what a
traffic snake snake yes what's that well
like one person stops and then everyone
else has to stop behind them oh and who
knows what the reason initially was that
for them to stop they could have been
you know an animal running into the road
or whatever creates a chain reaction
yeah it's crazy change reaction yeah
because we don't all work simultaneously
when we start accelerating yeah what
person has to go and then the next
person than the next person
yeah because of the traffic snake yeah
that is that is absolutely part of it
but anyway we don't need to go into the
math of traffic jams right now mostly
because I know very little about it only
enough to know it's pretty interesting
stuff okay next week we have a full week
of shows next week but Tuesday I will be
travelling as I do twice a year to Las
Vegas for Mike Papantonio 'he's mass
torts made perfect conference so Tuesday
we will have a guest post and I will be
broadcasting
for the rest of the week so that is it
for this week we'll talk to on Monday
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]